سرعان ماتلاشت فرحه سكان خرسا بتحرير
المدينه وسط القصف الروسي المكثف من الضفه
الشرقيه لنهر دنيرو ما تره الكثيرين
للفراع
القوات الروسيه قصفت جناح الولاده في
مستشفى في خيرسون ولم يصب احد باذى وتم
نقل الموظفين والمرضى الى ملجا حسب مصدر
رسمي
الاول خرجنا الى الممر من تلك الغرفه ثم
ذهبت الى غرفه الولاده وكان هناك طفل حديث
الولاده حملته وعدت به الى الممر كنت افكر
في ذلك الطفل وبنسائنا وبالاطفال الذين
نستقبلهم في هذا العالم بهذا الشكل المخيف
من اجل ماذا يفعلون ذلك
ولكن هيئه الاركان العامه للقوات المسلحه
الاوكرانيه افادت في تقريرها الصباحيه يوم
الاربعاء ان الثلاث 33 صاروخا روسيا تم
اطلاقها من راجمات صواريخ على اهداف مدنيه
في خيرسون خلال 24
وكل ما في وسعكم لمساعده مقاطعه
كانت القوات الروسيه انسحبت في الحادي عشر
من تشرين الثاني نوفمبر الماضي من مدينه
خرسون التي تتمتع باهميه استراتيجيه اذ
انها تقع وعندما صب نهر النيبرو وتعد
بوابه الى شبه جزيره القرم التي ضمتها
روسيا عام 2014